they've proposed oil taxes smoking taxes
you name it if there's you know there's
probably a tax on this video hi I'm Ted
Bala current reason TV and today I'll be
sitting down with John Fleischman
Fleischman is founder and publisher of
the flash report found that flash report
org a popular website that focuses on
California politics for those who may
not be familiar with it describe what
the flash report is flash report is a in
a nutshell is a website on California
politics most people have heard of The
Drudge Report and this is kind of the
California version our team gets up way
early every morning and goes to like a
hundred different websites and
consolidates all of the top news stories
of the day and then we kind of add to
that a lot of original writing from from
contributors up in that California last
year around this time California was in
a fiscal crisis this year were in
another fiscal crisis has anything
changed in a year a big a big part of
the reason why we're in a fiscal
precipice right now like wheeler were
last year is our state work force and
state budget have swelled to an enormous
size and then of course we have this
massive level of unsustainable defined
benefit retirement packages that have
been offered to all these employees and
so what you're gonna continue to see I
think is I think that there's a resolve
in Sacramento on the part of Republicans
to not support any more tax increases
that having been said I don't think
there's resolve amongst the Democrats in
Sacramento to really significantly cut
the size and scope of state government
but doesn't the GOP at least share some
of the blame I'm glad you asked me this
question because whether you look in
Washington DC where up until the very
end of george w bush's presidency we had
you know profligate spending taking
place in washington under republican
watch and then here in california i mean
last year's tax increase it takes a
two-thirds vote of the legislature to
increase taxes in California Democrats
don't control two-thirds of either
legislative chambers ergo Republicans
had some Republicans crossed over the
aisle and voted with the Democrats to
put these taxes on the Republican
governor's desk and he signed them so I
could tell you as an officer of the
Republican party when I travel all
around California I encounter a
tremendous amount of cynicism from loyal
Republicans who don't understand why
should we why should we be excited about
the Republican Party if the Republican
Party on its best day as being you know
kind of Democrat light and so what I say
to that is that I have seen you know
sometimes being in the minority can be
very helpful and certainly when you look
on the national perspective I mean III
believe that there's a different group
of Republicans who are now poised to to
lead in Washington if there's a
Republican majority and there's nothing
like a hard liberal president hardline
liberal president to encourage that and
then with Schwarzenegger you know you
have to remember he was elected in 2003
on a platform of sweeping out the
special interests and and we're not
going to raise taxes and I remember him
holding up the broom and and he turned
out to not be what what he told people
he would be I I always say that he in
retrospect he should have received an
Academy Award for best dramatic role in
a recall election because he really
fooled a lot of us I mean and and so
because of that it's really hurt the
party it's really hurt the party brand
the only good news is is that
Schwarzenegger seems to spend a lot of
his time trying to convince people he's
not a Republican really so where are we
headed is a federal bailout and the
works perhaps well I mean last year last
year a big chunk of money came from the
federal government out of that big
stimulus package as a president likes to
call it and this year Governor
Schwarzenegger has proposed a budget
that includes the presumption of getting
a another huge infusion of cash courtesy
of the taxpayers from around the country
I don't think that's a realistic
expectation and so I think we're gonna
end up in the in the spring here at
another big showdown that I think is
ultimately gonna end up being a mix of
cuts and then also um gimmicks which
we've seen before a lot of people are
predicting that California will just go
bankrupt but technically California
can't go bankrupt there's no
constitutional mechanism for it so what
would a fiscal collapse look like well I
mean this you know gets into an area of
theory because it's never happened
before
right now there's a real there's a
complex set of of constitutional
provisions and laws that have passed
that kind of prioritize okay if the
state has limited funds who gets first
shot at those funds and and it's like
this overlapping maze of commitments
that's it's very difficult to look
through but all we have to do is look at
you know whether we look in the private
sector it's a United Airlines is a great
example they went through a bankruptcy
reorganization and a huge chunk of the
liability they had on the books was to
their unions and to pension plans the
judge actually cracked open the pension
plan and talked about the need to revise
that and the employees came to the table
based on that and said you know what
this is where we agree to reduce what
our piece is because none of us are
going to get anything if the entire
company goes belly-up and and and
municipalities in California and
counties have the ability to go bankrupt
I mean declare bankruptcy Orange County
did a reorganization as you recall in
the 90s and it's still humming and
kicking today but it was able to
restructure a lot of its debt the city
of Vallejo up in Northern California has
gone through a bankruptcy and that was
that was sort of a microcosm of the
problems in California Vallejo had been
a ver that because they had so many
obligations to their pensioners they
literally figured out that in order to
pay all of the the money that was needed
for the pensions the city would have to
stop doing everything no fire no police
no no the libraries and so they're going
through a reorganization and and and
frankly I don't know if we'll actually
end up in that position or if you may
see a situation where ultimately the
legislature and the governor decide to
act only because they know that if they
don't some unelected judge is going to
start to make some some decisions
politicians like to talk about
across-the-board cuts and it's usually a
tiny percentage is there anything you
just get rid of I always like to say
that getting through the rest of arnold
schwarzenegger term if you're a Liberty
oriented individual is gonna be like
passing a kidney stone because he really
has turned out to not be what he
promised when he first got elected he
ordered this big California performance
review where they went through and they
reviewed all the nooks and crannies of
state government
and identified which at the time was
something like twenty billion dollars of
potential changes downsizing cuts and
then the whole thing got shelved because
the governor wasn't willing to take on
the union's most of those savings remain
yet to be realized because the political
will is not there on the part of the
Democrats to do it because you know for
example you know there is no reason why
you couldn't have the entire welfare
program for the state of California
administered in the private sector but
the public employee unions have fought
tooth and nail to make sure no public
employees have to administer welfare
well the cost of pub the public labor
force are tremendously higher than
contracting out to the private sector
and you know and then you know from
there you can go on and talk about the
state having hundreds of boards and
commissions that frankly serve no useful
purpose as a matter of fact at a time
when we should be eliminating boards and
commissions
I watched the the legislators
Republicans and Democrats just create
the new California blueberry Commission
now the blueberry Commission in and of
itself is not really that expensive
but symbolically it says to yours it
says to someone who's watching the
process these people don't get it it
seems like it's so clear that the
problem is spending why don't they get
it
I believe that there that for many of
them they have a passion that I would
almost call religious I mean they truly
believe in the welfare state they truly
believe in the role of state government
and redistributing wealth from those
people who have more to take care of
those people who have less and they
fight the shrinking of government in the
same way that the same zealousness than
which you would fight almost heresy I
think that they are hoping to weather
the storm that the economy is going to
come back if they could raise taxes they
would that there are more taxes proposed
this year than we've seen in many years
they're talking about taking they use
language and I like we're taking general
tax increases off the table this is
laughter last year when they increased
increased sales income car taxes by
about fourteen billion dollars this year
they're taking general tax increases off
the table but the translation to that is
they've proposed oil taxes smoking taxes
you name it if there's you know there's
probably a tax on this
I mean you know so they they want to get
more money out of the private sector at
a time when the economy is very
unhealthy and and the private sector can
least afford to invest more money in
government